all right well until then some honest
real reaction on the pro day workouts
that happened on wednesday it's more
important this year than any other year
because number one no scouting combine
where we got everybody together on an
apples to apples basis and number two no
private workouts where teams can get
secret information that we're never
privy to what they're getting is what
we're getting what they're seeing is
what we're seeing and one of the guys we
saw yesterday jamar chase at the lsu pro
day chris 438 in the 40. and you've been
on top of this idea that we just can't
accept that right being as accurate as
it would be in indy
but but still it's 438 right for a guy
that wasn't expected to crack 4-4
whether it's 4-3-8 or 4-4-8 it's still
pretty good no it is still really good
you're right i'm just trying to let
people know that those times you're
gonna see a lot more four threes this
year than you would in normal years
definitely but either way i mean jamar
chase
you know first off what you do is you
watch the film to go wait what does he
look like he runs like on film and he
looks like he runs 438 on film with the
way he plays with what he does with the
ball in his hand i mean all of this is
special you know his his l drill his 510
five i believe he went in like the three
nines if i'm correct pete like that
right there that's insane like three you
know the guys that go in three nine and
the three nines are usually like really
small slot type receivers this guy's you
know six foot over 200 pounds there's
real explosive movements with this
player and that's why he'll be a top 10
pick it's just i would be shocked if
he's not he's just one of those guys
that you know is special and has a
special way in which he carries himself
in a mature way on the football field he
was the best player in college football
non-quarterback wise last year as a true
sophomore um so really the sky's the
limit for this guy
the 41 inch standing vertical
was amazing
i it may have been more than 41 because
it looked like he got above the top
the top thing that you hit to flip it
around to prove how high you can jump i
mean that that was something and uh it
just it proves that this is one of the
top receivers in the draft here he is
from yesterday talking about the
possibility of going fifth overall to
the cincinnati bengals and being
reunited with his lsu quarterback joe
burrow
i have talked to the bengals um i don't
know how many times i've talked to them
though
um
but me and joe you know i i wouldn't
mind going back with joe um
you know if we go back together we
trying to do nothing but get back on
chemistry and have some more fun i think
i would have an advantage if i was to
play with him only because we played a
couple years
but
we'll still have to get that groove back
ahead you know feel for it again it's
not just going to be there when we throw
again so we have to build that chemistry
back up and work hard again
you have to wonder after that workout
yesterday now i i would say the bengals
at five or the ceiling i the falcons
with calvin ridley and julio jones even
if it is julio jones last year i i i
could see them going quarterback because
of the importance of the position
because matt ryan could be in his last
year i just think it would be too much
to go with a receiver at four which
would give the bengals a hell of an
option chase at five or
trade down to somebody who's desperate
to come up and get a quarterback and uh
and go elsewhere at the receiver
position that's going to be a decision
that they're going to have about 10
minutes to make but surely they'll have
a plan for what they're going to do
depending upon what those first four
picks may be yeah i mean i'm with you
and your thought there with the falcons
you know julio is there calvin ridley
has kind of i mean not kind of he's
established himself as a number one
receiver in football he's going to take
that you know thrown over once julia
leaves probably after next year the
bangles that's where it starts i mean
five and six we could see wide receiver
wide receiver right off the board right
there and then to you know both guys get
reunited with their old college
quarterbacks uh as far as that's
concerned
i'm i'm interested the bengal bengals of
course have some other needs on their
team would they go you know the the
offensive line route
i i don't know you know jamar chase is a
really special football players as is
devante smith i mean they're worthy of
that top 10 pick but i i would think
that's where it starts right there at
number five and that's the big reason i
think the dolphins got back up to number
six because they probably had some of
the same logic we we're talking about
they're going wait if we're at six
we're gonna get one of those two guys
you know most likely with how this
shakes out and and i would think their
logic about atlanta is similar to ours
we were asked about this yesterday on
pftpm the possibility that the dolphins
would have justin fields available to
them at six and would take him and if
that's what they would do that's the
ultimate gutsy
jedi mind trick all in move to drop out
of the third spot
to 12 back up to the sixth spot
and just kind of bide your time
and
and let fields fall through the cracks
to six and jump on him there i i doubt
that they would do it that would mean
that they're they they have real doubts
about tour that they're willing to act
on i agree with you i mean the dolphins
are a great spot to get one of these
great receivers whether it's demar chase
devonta smith the bengals are in great
position and the lions are in great
position yeah to get either either uh
jamar chase or the guy we're going to
talk about in a second here kyle pitts
the tight end out of four not that the
lions need him right lions don't need
him
but
um
i don't know yeah we see what the
patriots are trying to do with two tight
ends could you imagine the lions offense
with both tj hawkinson and kyle pitts
the way pitts performed yesterday yeah i
mean i don't think it's you know crazy i
don't you know it creates a lot of
mismatches those two tight end sets but
i'm with you and the fact that i think
my first thought is you know you're
gonna you're gonna take two tight ends
in the top ten of the draft two out of
three years i i i don't look at it but i
look at kyle pitts and his you know
again
mismatch nightmare
pounds runs 444
you know as smooth as can be running
routes you know has unbelievable ability
to you know one of those guys again mike
but when he's covered he's not covered
you could just throw it to him because
he's so athletic as far as adjusting the
ball i mean his 83-inch wingspan that he
had yesterday that's unreal to go along
with it so when you
that's where you know we talk about
chase devonte smith 5'6 to the dolphins
and bengals there you know i think kyle
pitts is probably in that conversation
too
to think like no it's all three of those
guys that are top 10 picks difference
makers for your football team and i do
think you know fit a positional need you
know maybe more so for the bangles and
the dolphins they do have gesicki who's
like that
um but but either way this is a top 10
pick and kyle pitts and jamar chase and
it's uh going to be interesting to see
where they both land
most eye-popping numbers for a tight end
since vernon davis who ran a sub 440 in
2006 and was a top 10 pick of the 49ers
and a great contributor at the nfl level
for a long period of time here's pitts
running that 4-4-4 83-inch wingspan the
largest of any receiver or tight end in
the last 20 years 83 inches makes it a
lot easier to complete passes when the
arms can fly out that wide and he's not
even
21 chris he turns 21 in october now tell
me if that body says to you tight end he
just looks like he looks like a really
big receiver and i wouldn't be surprised
if we we see him in the slot a lot and
maybe split out wide from time to time
that's what you're going to see him
doing the you know majority of stuff
will be that you know the first thing is
he'll get bigger he's going to be able
to put more just easy natural muscle
onto that frame there's no doubt but yes
i would think he gets used in that mold
of travis kelsey where he's extended
from the line of scrimmage a lot oh we
have him one on one out here with three
receivers over here wait oh all right
the linebacker went out on him oh it's
man-to-man okay well that
linebacker he can't cover you know kyle
pitts it's it's like the old new england
gronkowski aaron hernandez thing where
not only is it like a great you know
telltale sign when you have a tie dead
like pits and all of that it's like we
always talk about he's a pretty good
blocker to go along with it so now you
wait do we put in a nickel back because
we're worried about them throwing the
ball do we put in the other linebacker
because wait he could go to the
traditional tight end spot and they
could run the ball on us that's the
great value of a guy like that let alone
he has he has big time talent i mean he
does he's got the type of talent to be
up there in yards and reception leader
and be be one of the best in the game
here's pitts talking about one of the
teams that could be taking him in the
top five the atlanta falcons
i didn't talk to myself a couple times
and i talked to my head today and
they're saying they have interest in me
and uh after after today we'll get back
on another zone you know they'll try and
learn more about myself so
i feel like they're pretty interested in
you know it would be a dream come true
to be even be top five or the first
uh non-quarterback to come on the board
thing to remember about this year that
makes it different from other years the
zoom
availability every team can talk to
every prospect there's a limit to the
number of times you can talk to each one
but you can talk to all of them if you
want to so it's not quite the same as
who's taking a visit where who's getting
a private workout where but this is a
guy who yeah he's not going to be there
when the 10th pick rolls around chris
the question is who's going to jump on
him and who's going to end up having a
great weapon he said that no one has
talked to him about playing receiver on
a full-time basis look at that six five
245 runs a four four four eighty three
inches i'd say the hell with tight end
i'm making this guy my number one
receiver well you know there's little
short area quick movements that
i would say are not on par with a guy
like joe marsh chase and devonte smith
you know as far as like explosiveness is
concerned that way but still yeah mike
you're right there's a lot of traits
there he's gonna be using that the name
of the game will be like what we talked
about he's going to be utilized like a
travis kelsey like a darren waller with
the
the las vegas raiders you know yeah
you'll see some from the traditional set
but you're going to see plenty of him
split out and it doesn't really matter
you know again he's going to be one of
those things where it's oh linebacker or
safety's covered him well he's faster
and more athletic than them oh wait they
put a corner on him well he's bigger
than them they he'll box him out he'll
use his body to shield him so uh it's
plenty of receiver will be in his future
that that will be the value of him but
when you're that big and he's a willing
blocker he's gonna be a pain in the butt
you know as far as trying to figure out
how to match up with him when he's on
the football field we talked about chase
the number one receiver on chris's board
at the position two of the others in the
top six worked out yesterday florida's
cadarius tony yeah and lsu's terrace
marshall what did you see from them that
that made you either feel good
about why they're where you have them or
made you think man i'm too low or maybe
i got them too high well no i i don't i
don't feel any different about where i
got him ranked or anything like that
cadarius tony i mean is a is a weapon
he's a like a special athlete who needs
polish as a wide receiver but
has too many just raw skills and
explosiveness and speed
to
nitpick too much about oh his route
running yeah he's gonna have to work on
that but he's gonna be dangerous with or
without the ball in his hand the guy
that like people are sleeping on a
little bit is the guy you see at number
six there terrace marshall jr i mean
he
is the one i think that he
i was impressed with his pro day
yesterday one listen i i think he's a
first-round talent he's a lot like
justin jefferson was last year maybe a
hair faster but i think the thing that
jumped out to me about the pro day a
little with him is there's a little i
didn't realize he was as thick and as
put together is the way he is that's
what excites me there so he's got really
good quick feet he's got the ability to
be like tough and strong over the middle
like justin jefferson was and and
honestly i think there's maybe a little
bit more big play ability with uh
terrace marshall i'm not sure he's the
overall as good a wide receiver but
might have a little more straight line
speed than justin jefferson did and we
know how special he was for your vikings
last year
kyle trask florida quarterback not one
of your top six but
a guy whose name has been mentioned as
one of the top candidates this year what
were your thoughts on his performance
and and does it push him up the stack at
all i think it does because because his
film is underwhelming he's a really big
guy with a slow delivery slow feet you
know
for as big as he is he doesn't
necessarily stand in there with the
trash around them like you would like to
there's a lot of like wait why are you
falling backwards there's nobody around
you type throws you know
so on film it's good but it's not great
but the biggest issue i had was just
going no man this day and age this
quarterback right here with this long
you know elongated release and kind of
clunky feet and everything like that
this this is an outdated quarterback
but i do think he really helped himself
yesterday as far as the pro day is
concerned one he changed the way he
looked he lost a lot of weight you know
which i first want to go wait you're a
quarterback how are we overweight to
begin with that to me is a warning sign
but he did
look a lot better as far as just popping
around and put moving his feet and
popping them underneath them and on the
move those type of things to where it
changed the look of the player a little
bit and even with the throwing motion it
was quicker you know so all of it was
better and i do think is going to make
teams feel a little bit better about him
i'm interested to see where he ends up
mike because i think he's one of those
guys where there'll be a few people that
really like him in the nfl and maybe he
is that part of that next group that
goes off the board after the big six but
i think there's also a group of people
in the nfl going to look at him and just
go no these quarterbacks don't work
anymore this day and the age in the nfl
and i i don't i don't want to deal with
it so be interesting
and the reality is the faster they come
off at the top of the draft the more
likely the other guys
go
sooner than usual because even though
teams say we're taking the best
available player their assessment of
best available is always driven by their
actual
needs and if they fly off early there
will be more who come off the board
later
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports